hello there I'm gavel Cammisa lemon goes
video now a Taser being fired is a
highly requested to me waving like an
idiot highly requested video but can
never get hold of one so I flew to
Scottsdale in Arizona to Taser HQ to
fire some tasers this is the cartridge
we're using it's for the x26 model it's
a one shot cartridge and a we're going
to be using the V 25:11 which is an
extremely fast camera because tasers are
extremely fast give me a countdown three
two one this was recorded a thousand
frames a second and as you can see still
way too fast
so the b25 eleven will shoot twenty
eight thousand five hundred frames a
second HD as you can see the penetration
of the prongs is pretty solid you want
to aim sort to split the belt line
that's where they usually aim so one
above one below the belt so here's a
close-up shot at twenty eight thousand
five hundred frames a second of a taser
being deployed
we
and now I'm gonna get a front unshot of
the Taser being fired
so you're probably wondering at this
point what's up with the confetti and
these are actually known as the aphids
it's a good way of tracking which taser
has been deployed who fired it because
each tiny piece of confetti has the
serial number of the cartridge that
fired it very clever because you could
never pick them all up so Dan's not here
today but luckily we've got someone else
called Dan I'm right down and Dan what
do you what do you do for a living
oh I play with these cameras a lot and
somehow you've been roped into getting
yeah exposed with a Taser in a slow mo
guys video apparently they feel like you
know I need some payback for bringing
cameras these guys a Taser ok Dan would
you relax three to five seconds
if I speed up the shot slightly you can
see that from the point of impact his
muscles contract from right to left
across his shoulders look at that
damn thoughts ah would you do that again
when I do to get if you had to you told
me a lot of someone would be paying some
heavy price oh that is fully in there
like do you feel it in you right now I
don't really feel the probes I feel like
you know it feels like I'm you know my
muscles are locked up is what it feels
like how was that how's the stomach
contents it will remain yes I wasn't
I do not wet my bed life is good was the
noise involuntary oh I just coming out I
could coma I think that was more of it
was party just I think that was more of
just my body convulsing and pushing this
pretty matter though it wasn't it wasn't
like it was enchanted it sound pretty
guess like kind of brave part it wasn't
like ha ha ha look at that ripple going
through the back jeez so keeping the
trend alive of torturing people named
Dan if Dan's not here I guess a second I
always willing to step up their game I
hope you enjoyed that video thanks to
taser for letting me come a film at
their HQ you can buy shirt if you want
and this is a pretty gross shot of the
prong being pulled out their barbs they
don't bounce out on impact so uh to get
them out you need to give them a nice
little tug or speaking of Tasers there
is a Taser in the super-awesome
upcoming movie lazer team I'm in it it
comes out in winter here's some of the
trailer thanks for watching
why the hell are we lazer team anyway
because I have a laser yeah what the
rest of us don't right you're the team
part nobody cares about your stupid name
the Talmud heightens all mental
functions and other visual enhancements
yes